emploi recrutement et transport voici
quelquesuns des sujets abordés lors de
cette réunion d'un côté des
représentants de cquenttin en Eveline
responsable de l'économie et de
l'insertion professionnelle de l'autre
des entrepreneurs du territoire une
première rencontre pour parler de leur
besoins et la stratégie à mettre en
place par l'agglomération pour les aider
on voit bien qu'il y a des demandeurs il
y a de l'offre mais comment ça doit
matcher correctement ça a été la grosse
problématique de ce matin voilà et on
voit que ça matche pas bien sur certains
secteurs ce que nous avons retenu euh
prioritairement c'est sur ces forums de
l'emploi donc c'est quelque chose que
nous avions déjà mis en en exerg il y a
quelques temps mais là puisque nous
sommes rentrés avec les 12 communes
évidemment nous allons réactiver sur les
12 communes donc ça c'est vraiment un
point très positif le recrutement une
des principales problématiques évoquées
ce matin ces entrepreneurs cherchent à
recruter en priorité sur le territoire
pourtant il rencontre souvent des
difficultés pour y parvenir notre
problème je dirais le plus immédiat
c'est d'avoir accès à un calendrier des
prochains forums pour pouvoir nous en
interne nous organiser et surtout ne pas
rater un seul événement qui nous
permettrait la mise en contact avec de
potentiels candidats en plus de ces
échanges une enquête est menée avec des
questionnaires deux autres rencontres
comme celles-ci sont prévu pour intégrer
les entrepreneurs des 12 communes de
l'agglomération aujourd'hui les
entreprises elles regardent euh vous sa
c'est ce qu'on appelle le B2B B2C B2
mten non c'est le B2 territory donc
c'estàd que voilà c'est avec le
territoire les entreprises regardent
quelle est la qualité des services
emploi du territoire donc de
l'agglomération prochain rendez-vous le
22 septembre à plaisir et le 29 à
Promopole un séminaire emploi sera par
la suite organisé le 17 octobre afin de
prolonger cette dynamique d'amélioration
du recrutement
local